you're watching sky news in just a
moment the press preview our first look
at what's on the front pages as they
arrive first though our top stories here
tonight and a red danger to life weather
warning for tomorrow schools are closed
and rail services suspended as
forecasters say storm eunice could bring
record winds to much of the uk
america's vice president kamala harris
has arrived in germany tonight ahead of
a security conference in munich tomorrow
which will be dominated by concerns of a
possible russian invasion into ukraine
and a swimmer killed in a shark attack
in australia has been named as a british
man simon nellis the 35 year old was an
experienced diving instructor and was
engaged to be married
[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive so it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
olivia utley and ian dunt so a very good
evening to both of you good to see you
both and i'm very pleased to say that
they will both be with us from now until
just before midnight so let's take a
look then at what's making the front
pages and red alert is the metro's
headline as storm eunice bears down on
the uk threatening widespread damage and
even a threat to life
the eye says the country is braced for
winds of 100 miles an hour in what's
been described as a rare sting jet storm
and a similar take to the daily mail
the sun describes it as the 100 miles
per hour killer storm
the financial times meanwhile leads with
joe biden's warning to western allies
that russia could invade ukraine within
the next few days
the daily telegraph says that biden and
boris johnson believe what they call
false flag attacks to give russia an
excuse to invade have already begun
and it's the same story for the guardian
the times reports that whitehall is
convinced putin is about to invade
inhumane is the mirror's headline the le
they lead with an investigation into how
shortfalls in social care have forced
thousands of elderly people out of their
homes
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code that you'll see on screen during
the program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers for yourself
while you watch us
so let's bring in olivia ugly and ian
dunphy to go through some of those front
pages and a lot of them olivia dominated
by the warnings of
big storm coming storm eunice with a red
alert for
the south west and parts of south wales
as well quite a rare warning that isn't
it
yeah it sounds like it's going to be the
worst storm in over 30 years um it's
being compared to the 1987 storm which
obviously destroyed uh huge huge swathes
of uh forestry in the uk um those are
120 mile winds these are 100 mile winds
so not quite as bad uh compares more
closely to the burns day storm of 1990
in which 47 people died um so it's it's
a pretty big deal and people are being
advised not to travel there are no
trains operating in the whole of wales
tomorrow people are being told to stay
at home
um
not walk near the sea
uh it it's it's pretty scary and it and
it's coming tomorrow it's right on the
back of storm dudley
that's right storm dudley
particularly affected the north of
england and scotland of course and and
ian if we look at the sun as well
they've got 100 miles per hour killer
storm and similar headlines on a number
of the other papers as well and to some
extent i i guess
these headlines are useful for a
government trying to encourage people
to to heed warnings and not go out
yeah we're quite far away from that
experience in 1987 aren't we where our
main feeling was that we hadn't been
suitably warned and even i mean i was
very young when that happened but i
remembered that that was the first thing
people talking about the next day it was
the lack of warning and of course that
famous michael bush uh sort of footage
of him sort of down playing it something
she later claimed did not take place
this time that's not what we're getting
we're getting pretty much full bore
tabloid and broadsheet warnings i mean
the met office stuff it's sort of quite
hard to know what to do with some of it
i read it i'm not in a sort of red
warning area i'm in an amber warning
area but for red warning areas it was
they should take steps to protect your
property you know and to protect
yourself within the property and i sort
of thought well i'm not entirely sure
what what that is what we could possibly
be doing that would achieve that it
seems that at the moment the
recommendation is basically just stay in
your house which shouldn't be too hard
because it looks like this thing hits at
about 3am and should be mostly over with
by 9am in my very quick research project
on what this kind of storm entails it
seems that it is fierce but it doesn't
last very long well yes and i think for
the red area i think i'm right in saying
it it's in place between seven and
midday for those for that southwest area
but yes you're right and some of the
advice that um people have been talking
to me about is you know to make sure
that you know garden furniture anything
that could could be whipped up by a
strong wind should make sure that that's
secure but but you're right there's a
certain amount that and people
can't can't do if you've got trees or or
tiles coming off roofs you just have to
avoid going out don't you olivia but i
guess given that there is this strong
warning from the mets the big question
will be
how
what the response is like once the storm
happens whether or not
power is reconnected quickly if it's
lost somewhere if trees are cleared off
roads and and if there is flooding how
that's dealt with that they'll the test
will come after the event
yeah absolutely and we all remember the
the storm a few months ago or in
scotland and the north of england which
was actually kind of shamefully ignored
by quite big parts of the london media
um or not ignored but but underplayed uh
but there were people who were living
without electricity for for days and in
some cases in some cases weeks um so
it's that it's whether you know that
we're ready to respond to a storm like
this which will be the test in in days
to come but as ian said it does feel
like we're quite well prepared we've
been talking about this for for a few
days now so there's no excuse really if
um if the emergency measures aren't in
place to get get lives back on track
once once the storm has passed which
hopefully will be
by tomorrow afternoon absolutely let's
hope that it doesn't leave too much
damage but but ian i guess um as well
it'll be a test for various flood
defenses as well i mean we have had
warnings haven't we from the environment
agency that i think they put out a
report saying adapt or die they're
saying that we're going to get more
extreme weather events with climate
change in future so that money has to be
invested to make sure that we can
protect ourselves against the worst
damage that it might cause
yeah and i mean the flood argument is
made almost every year almost every year
we have a story of severe flooding that
is told that we could have done more to
defend ourselves against it and could
more quickly deal with the ramifications
of it and these storms themselves i
don't
i'm going to put a health warning on
this as well because then maybe that i'm
called up by the environment i'll be on
it but my understanding is that this is
not this is just something that happens
it is not connected towards climate
change but of course we are seeing more
extreme weather events you can feel the
mildness of this winter as well as an
indication of that you need an effective
system for it an effective system to
deal with the aftermath
exactly so
storms covering a lot of the front pages
but the ukraine situation once again uh
featuring prominently as well olivia you
picked out the telegraphs of front page
and they've got a picture of boris
johnson there on the cover in the
cockpit of a typhoon fighter jet their
headline russia begins false flag
attacks and um perhaps you should remind
us what false flag attacks are if you
can as well
yeah so this is this is very worrying
and it's exactly the sort of sign that
we were hoping not to see um it's that
that uh russia is trying to make ukraine
look bad there's been a sort of skirmish
in the donbasque region of of ukraine um
and russia is trying to pin the blame on
ukraine and act as though the ukrainian
military is being aggressive um so that
it has an excuse is the idea to to then
invade ukraine and obviously you know
biden and johnson and other
western leaders uh sort of see straight
through that but that is one of the the
seven signs the telegraph talks about
that uh
that an invasion is coming when we start
seeing these false flag attacks when we
start seeing
russia try to paint ukraine as uh
aggressive militarily then we should
start to worry and the fact that we're
seeing it now suggests that you know
these reports over the last few days
that the briefings that that russia is
actually stepping back from the
ukrainian border sounds like uh it was
just sort of talk from the kremlin and
we're we're sort of ramping up ready
again as we were a few days ago for this
invasion and i think you know it plays
into putin's hands really doing this he
says he's drawing back he says and then
he does these false flag attacks and
it's coming forwards again and he's got
the west sort of wrapped around his
little finger just waiting on his every
move which is exactly where he wants us
well yes and it is very difficult to
judge the situation isn't it um clearly
leaders are expressing concern if we
look at the front page of the financial
times they've got the u.s president joe
biden's warning russia poised to invade
ukraine within days he said um so it is
very difficult to know where we are now
does it feel to you as if that window of
opportunity for diplomacy is closing how
do you read it
no you can't make any judgments about
the situation at all and that's on
purpose that's a weaponized form of
uncertainty deployed by putin he's been
deploying this for a very long time now
if you think back you know when we had
the opening of the troubles in ukraine
go back to 2014 and the shooting down of
mh17 i mean look what happened after
that plane crashed we had reliable
information later demonstrated beyond
any reasonable doubt this was a result
of russian actions of russian forces
accidentally shooting the plane down but
troll farms
in moscow in saint petersburg making
sure that they would just muddy the
water that's how they operate that's how
the regime operates it's not to create
some parallel truth that you believe
it's just to create an inability to form
certain judgments about the objective
world and that is precisely the tactic
that you're seeing deployed here the
talk about the skirmishes the talk about
aggression one hand on the other when of
course if you just step back for a
moment you realize there wouldn't be
anyone in that region in the first place
if it wasn't for russia's animosity back
in 2014 there wouldn't be troops around
ukraine now if it wasn't for the fact
that russia had chosen to deploy them
there it is the clear aggressor
but instead it's broiled up in that
disinformation and uncertainty that
makes it almost impossible to form
coherent judgments about it and olivia
what do you make of how the west have
used information as well we have seen um
similar statements from from leaders
haven't we but we also saw an
interesting thing today the british
well our ministry of defense put out a
document it was called an access of
invasion document that seemed to outline
invasion routes that they thought that
it was possible that russia could take
do you see a kind of
are you surprised by the handling of
this and the way that
western allies are talking about the
possible threats
yeah i mean today we have seen sort of
coherent messaging from from biden and
johnson uh they're both warning that
this attack could be coming but yeah as
you say in the past few days we've got
this document from from our ministry of
defense um and then you've got the u.s
uh warning about
you know suggesting particular days that
russia might invade ukraine and it feels
like the kind of rumor mill is sort of
spinning um and it seems like it's it's
a little bit sort of out of control it
doesn't seem like there's there's one
unified western response and again that
sort of and you know we've also seen
macron and schultz uh taking a slightly
different line to boris johnson um and
again that plays into putin's hands
because part of his his strategy seems
to be to to prove that the west is
divided um and even if the invasion
doesn't doesn't go ahead it'll be quite
hard for europe and the west to sort of
claim that as a win because putin has
has proved really what he needed to
prove which is that europe and america
can't really present a totally united
front on this um we're all doing our own
separate things preparing for invasion
occasionally we come together with one
sort of joint statement or at least
statements echoing each other but quite
a lot of the time our response seems a
little bit all over the place okay we're
going to take a break right now lots
more to talk about in just a moment
including the daily mail's message to
the royal brothers who they described as
the pampered princess
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me tonight olivia ugly and
ian dunst so welcome back to both of you
and and ian at the papers still
have coverage of both prince andrew and
prince charles who have hit the
headlines earlier in the week the daily
mail
poses the question it's one of the
columnists writing about it when will
pampered princes realize the age of
deference is over it's not been a great
week for the royal family has it
no this is about as bad a week for the
royal family as i can remember
i mean certainly since the death of
princess diana it's hard to think of
anything worse and the firm would have
taken substantial pr damage over this
that it probably won't quite get over
there'd always be that slight smell that
whiff of association with epstein with
what went on there when you come up with
a settlement this is pretty much what
happens no you know there's no clarity
provided there's no sense of certainty
on either side so you just get the smell
of it the stench of it lingers without
any real sense of resolution but do you
think probably that common piece gets a
little bit over excited i mean there's a
part where the suggestion of maybe
charles who's embroiled or at least his
charity is in broad and questions around
the corruption inquiry we're still not
sure of any of the firm details on that
yet whether perhaps charles will just
have to step aside and william will
become king when the queen goes
something okay i think we we may need to
calm down a little bit here and take
things one step at a time because i
think that's really quite unlikely to
happen even if it does speak to this
quite long-lasting
hatred of charles in some parts of the
left wing and the right-wing press this
this real discomfort with him and a
desire to see him hurt i don't think we
have any evidential basis to think that
things would be that severe right now
well yes and there's an article inside
at the metro isn't there again asking
the question of how the settlement that
prince andrew has agreed with virginia
jeffrey will be paid for their headline
is queen chips in with two million for
andrew's settlement but various figures
about the total being a lot more than
that of course between 10 and 12 million
i think has been um
muted
olivia do you think that the public are
going to change their opinion of the
royal family with with stories like this
i mean after all it's supposed to be the
year of celebrating the royals with the
queen's platinum jubilee
i sort of agree with the end that there
is a danger of getting a bit too
overexcited and you know 30 years ago
that scandals like this in the royal
family were very rare but ever since the
queen's you know anna cereblis in 1992 i
think it was um there have been quite a
lot of scandals to hit the royal family
and they do seem to weather them and i
think the queen's personal popularity
helps with that and also charles of
course there is a lingering dislike of
charles among among some sections of
britain but but actually i thought that
the response to camilla being called
queen camilla uh when when charles was
made king was very muted and actually
quite supportive um across much of
british decision not to offer finance so
i think you know astute's towards
charles are very much softening so i
think definitely the royal family will
weather this um that that piece about
andrew is just astonishing really he's
feeling relatively chipper apparently
and he's thinking about the future
perhaps taking another public role which
is
what is he thinking but you know okay
there we go we must leave it there but
i'm pleased to say you're both gonna be
back with me at 11 o'clock so we can
revisit some of these stories and some
new ones
a little bit later so thanks very much
indeed for now